Imaginez : on estime que l'ensemble des
cyberfraudes (par téléphone, par texto,
par courriel) aurait coûté environ 8 milliards
de dollars aux canadiens de 2013 à 2017.
Il y a, au bas mot, des dizaines
de milliers de victimes.
La « fraude amoureuse », dans laquelle
quelqu'un établit un lien avec vous et
vous demande de l'argent, est la plus
rentable pour les criminels.
Mais celle dont on parle le plus en
2018, parce que tout le monde a reçu
cet appel, c'est la fraude de l’Agence
du Revenu du Canada.
Un criminel, qui est souvent
à l'étranger, personnifie un employé de
l'Agence et vous demande de rembourser des
impôts maintenant, et ça presse.
Ceux qui sont les plus vulnérables face
à cette fraude : les personnes âgées, les
nouveaux arrivants, les gens qui sont
isolées et ceux qui sont mal informés.
Il y en a peut-être dans votre entourage et
vous ne le savez peut-être même pas,
parce qu'à peine 5 % des gens dénoncent
ce crime.
Alors, prenez le risque d'être impoli.
Si vous recevez un appel d'organisme,
raccrochez. Vous pourrez ensuite
rappeler un numéro connu de
l'organisme en question. Mais d'abord et
avant tout, raccrochez.